what do you think about the tic tac ufo
that uh david fraver and others have
cited
that's such a you know truly anomalous
experience um
i can't
i can't
do like mental models in my head to
find potential solutions to
discredit that right like as much as i
try right just as a logical process as a
practice i can't i can't pick it apart
in in the way that we were just talking
about a moment ago about you know
thousands of drones being like sent up
in very tricky manners right i can't
really bring myself to
a clever solution that you know other
than just saying the pilots are lying or
is there you know and i believe you know
i i know dave fravor you know i consider
him a friend we talk a lot um i have
zero zero reason to disbelieve anything
he says
yeah i agree with you uh
but in terms of the actual ufo
is there something anomalous and
interesting to you about that particular
case maybe
one interesting aspect there is
how much do i understand about the
water surface and underwater aspects of
these ufos it seems like a lot of the
discussions about is about the movement
of
this particular thing that seems to be
weird anomalous seems to defy physics
but what about stuff that's happening
underwater that's interesting to me
if i had advanced technology i would
certainly
like to operate in part underwater
because you can hide a lot of stuff
there
you think it would be somewhat as easy
as traveling through interstellar space
at least right yeah um
you know i wish i had a great answer for
that but as an aviator
that's a kind of a black box for us we
don't have great what i would call cross
domain tracking right i can't see
something go under water and then follow
it underwater so it's literally not your
domain like underwater like leave that
for somebody else yeah and you know i i
use that terminology because it's it's
kind of important right um cross-domain
tracking uh is something that we haven't
had to necessarily worry about right
because airplanes operated in the air
and
submarines operated underwater and space
planes operating space right but you
know there's going to be
you know that's going to blur i think as
as we move along here especially in the
air and space regime
and being able to perhaps transition my
radar contact at 40 000 feet to another
radar system that can track it up to 200
000 feet
you know that might be a value and so we
seem to be missing that right now
you